bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
my dear la dr jazz si dovrebbe essere in
stile tipo med padre o ibra una cosa
così su su jeff the killer che sarebbe
un krypi pasta famosissimo ti trovo dire
il mio caro fratello jack non so quanto
può essere caro effettivamente ma direi
di andare a scoprirlo stati new game boy
di jeff era era una mattinata come tante
altre ma aveva uno strano presentimento
lo sai quel presentimento in cui il
tutto succede come non dovrebbe
ok siamo partite che bello mi sembra di
giocare a poker hanno una cosa del
genere ma il no il personaggio
principale un figo o come il
presentimento ragazzi questo gioco sarà
una figata deve prima chiesto tizio
buongiorno come stai
la giusta è la risposta più azzeccata
questo tizio che è che bellissimo che
stato fare come stai sto bene ok hai
visto tua madre
sembra che sia in cucina e dove cazzo è
la cucina di qua a perfetto domanda
ricco a ema ditemelo ciao tesoro vi
fuori colazione si prepara min 2 toast
donna
no grazie sì grazie mamma devo cosa
facciamo
devo studiare adesso ma chi è che
studiano la mattina a chi lavora e
contare zio che come arrivi in chiave
lati sfondi di pizze che non è una cosa
e poi diventi grasso non va bene
dobbiamo andare in camera a studiare e
poi avere come fratello ger the killer
non deve essere proprio il massimo credo
questi qui ok york fantastico è la
stessa cosa è successo chi ti ha detto
gli attori il joker abbiamo fatto un
grosso stack a me la regala una camera
in casa mia e crossa quanto camera sua
cioè aiuti ma di andare a camminare un
po stavo studiando come un bravo bambino
e tu devi dirmi di uscire vabbè usciamo
dai ricordi quando avevi otto anni si è
perché mi fai questa domanda avevi un
amico immaginario quando giocavamo tutte
le volte si chiamava jeffrey no
intendevo che non era così immaginario
come pensavi sta dicendo cosa
assolutamente senza senso avevi davvero
un fratello è solo mera jeffrey jaime
ricordi quando la casa andò a fuoco e
nell'orario appunto fratello a darle
fuoco e pivot
sì ma se cose si dicono quando già 25
anni o potevi dirgliele prima ragazzi io
non andrei
vederlo l'ospedale è del central
hospital fantastico io non andrei a
vedere dobbiamo andare a visitarlo ma
chi cazzo sei un bravo ragazzo io
purtroppo non durerà molto mi sa
vabbè comunque devo andare a incontra il
mio fratello già per i ragazzi non siete
contenti ragazzi sinceramente c'è una
paura [ __ ] di come andrà a finire a
buongiorno le sta sfuggendo di mano il
carrello se non se n'è accorto ma vabbè
anche se in realtà non ho la più pallida
idea di dove sia ma andiamo così a caso
camera 123 come la 10 jeff i dream è
perfetto camera 10 o andato a caso credo
sia questa qui è suonata la campanella
va in classe questa nell'ospedale ha
preso fuoco
no no per favore devo vedere mio
fratello non ha importanza
voglio vederlo ragazzi sta dando fuoco
tutto jeffrey dove sei
perché c'è scritto dai sul muro così di
violenza cosa devo fare spegnete il
fuoco da dallara l'acqua del cesso dai
forza ok non funziona ragazze portategli
estintori qualcosa perché questa
buongiorno e qualcuno voglia di spegnere
il fuoco perché un casino lì dentro io
me ne vado
ciao a tutti bene io torno indietro
dispiace cosa lui non era nello spedale
e dove cazzo era dove dovete infatti la
traduzione è questa più o meno
ho chiamato mia madre e non c'è stata
risposta mamma risponde sempre prega sta
diventando qualcosa non andava ha
commesso da vito ragazzi e non sta
succedendo quello che penso vero sono
tornato a casa correndo più più forti e
veloce che potresti e l'ho visto che sta
ci sta
ragazzi allora io non ho capito che cosa
diavolo è successo però l'ospedale è
andato a fuoco
mia madre non risponde al telefono la
cosa è veramente orribile credo poi vado
vado a logiche o poi non lo so credo sia
questo non perché si deve fare tre
chilometri per andare al cesso
buongiorno gesture che cazzo stai
facendo e che anzi sta diventato che
tantissimo per quel coltello poi salva
il coltello jeffrey cosa che conta è la
tua faccia quale faccia casa non sanno
bellissimo sì sì stupendo cazzo sia un
modello di abercrombie papa non ha
voluto la cina sia nostro party ma non
ha importanza
guardalo adesso ok no tesoro papa
[ __ ] jeff sei pazzo non ti dessero
entrare nella mia vita uscire a mio
padre qual è il tuo problema jeff avete
lasciato in quell'ospedale maledetto per
14 anni 14 anni pagherete per questo
inizieremo con te mamma dai volutamente
nota scappa mamma ci penso io a lei è
andata via
possiamo giocare all'oscurità sarà
divertente
oh cazzo credo di avere la mia torcia
nella tasca arrivando salva mamma uccidi
jaffe scappa da casa
oddio
[Musica]
silvio ma velinista al campo perché non
sai dove te lo metto quel coltello
mai così te lo faccio ce la fa ce la fa
ce la faccio scappa veloce brutto
stronzo
no no no fermo fermo fermo [ __ ] ok
ok ok non mi sta proseguendo
non mi sto seguendo non mi stupisco i
libri i libri ok io libri ok dove c'è il
sapere non mi raggiungerà ragazzi siamo
al sicuro perché questi sono dei libri
scolastici che sono un repellente per i
ragazzi quindi dovremmo essere a posto
mi fai muovere per favore se hai voglia
e non lo so ok va bene va bene non fa
niente
l'ha fatto ancora mi ha ucciso nel letto
tra l'altro ragazzino negli anni dove
sia mia madre come cazzo faccia andare a
trovarla che ne so io vado alla aspetta
un attimo di qua in cucina le madri si
trovano sempre in cucina jack [ __ ]
2 ecco il coltello di merda fatti un
tramezzino alla nutella invece di
rompermi le palle allora devo andare a
trovare dove mia madre
devo devo devo trovare mia madre
assolutamente prima che quel tizio mi
stupri
ok ci siamo ci siamo mamma mia che
raggiro che raggiro potente dovesse dove
mia madre ma porca [ __ ] si è appena
uscito di là come fai ad arrivare dalle
scale [ __ ]
ho capito ho capito ho capito ho capito
tanto non mi porti più ho capito ragazzi
aspettate un attimo forse forse sì so
non credo che lui entri nelle stanze in
base alla velocità quindi in base a
quanto io faccio veloce poi lui mi mi
spunta addosso venisse io vado subito a
prendere la chiave poi me ne esco credo
di vincere tipo così veloce veloce
veloce
ok ok adesso via dal cazzo via dai cazzo
di nel caso che la cazzo cazzo
penso che ci credo non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
ok allora adesso che ciò sta maledetta
chiave dove la uso dovrebbe essere tipo
questa forse sì cioè grande sono solo
fuori libertà andiamo a cercare i
pokémon nomi spunta un bel basa freddo
che devo trovare il modo di uscire di
casa credo non lo so anche perché stiamo
cercando è chiuso ce l'avevo io la
chiave va bene lo ammetto sono stato li
ha rubati le caramelle con tre anni ti
giuro
niente la chiave è stata trovata una
chiave stato provato che hai penso sia
per call per il coso fuori perché non
c'è nient'altro richiuso ma qualcosa mi
dice che la chiave mi apre questo però
si può trovare a perfetto raga perfetta
c'è una chiazza di sangue grossa più
della mia testa
cos'è sta roba non vedo niente che cazzo
così perché ci sono chiazze di sangue
ovunque testa porta era chiusa prima
della benzina la benzina per cosa forse
per un accendino o qualcosa del genere
cos'è sarà utile un'ascia una shabie
niger dove sei già fino dove sei
vieni che ti dà una mano il tuo
fratellino famiglia e dove sei ragazzi 9
cos'è mettere la torcia nella lampada si
sta cosa può essere tagliata usa lascia
se grandissimo cos'è 312 qua
vabbè 3 1 2 4 5 poi ricordatevi questo
poi ditemelo nel caso comunque cos'è sta
roba qui aspetta un attimo asp e da
fermi fermi sono uscito dal gioco c'è
una combinazione nel guardaroba perché
un guardaroba dovrebbe mai avere una
combinazione 31 24
ok lo trovava l'ho trovato la chiave
dell'uscita la chiave dell'uscita non ci
posso credere
fatemi uscire ragazzi ho trovato la
chiave dell'uscita che forse è quella
per uscire se si chiama così
effettivamente [ __ ] già primo che
allora facciamo così speriamo che trovi
dei pokémon così siano impegnato non ha
trovato nessuno
[Musica]
musica allora facciamo così facciamo
avanti e indietro non lo facciamo mai
biglietto perché ti stanchi primo ok
sono ragazzi allora fatemi capire dove
devo usare st chiave credo all'uscita se
quello mi ci fa andare all'uscita però
se no è un casino aspettate come fa devo
fare giro melo a giro sto tizio ok ok
sì sì sì ci siamo ci siamo ci si
affaccia posso fare non è così difficile
ciò posso fare ce la posso fare ce la
posso fare è chiusa una sola può aprire
cielo lascia cielo la sua sponda sponda
oggi cazzo
siamo vivi per miracolo non ci posso
credere perché c'è del sangue cosa sta
succedendo cos'è allora forse le tracce
di sangue qui sono dei vicini camia ok
ok ragazzi stiamo per arrivare al punto
credo dove ok
buongiorno buongiorno c'è nessuno qui
dietro non voglio vedere che cosa c'è
dietro queste tende neanch'io voglio
vedere ma devi farlo ma non l'ha fatto
perfetto e io pensavo stesse scherzando
non lo fa proprio a ragazzi cioè io mi
ha messo mezz'ora per arrivare qui e poi
non apre lette io io sono qui di
passaggio e ho trovato un qualcosa di
nascosto dietro questo quadro ho trovato
una magnum 9 mm io torno indietro per
tentare di ucciderlo perché sono non so
che cosa fare ok io e 6 fratellino
adesso non si fa più vedere lo stronzo
dove cazzo ragazzi credo che gioco si è
cambiato da jack the killer a favi da
quella credo che sia così anche se cos'è
sta roba che ancorano capito cos'è
usa lascia per aprire la piccola porta
lascia in rotta fantastico che cazzo est
a porta credo che abbia usato questo
condotto per raggiungerci lui è pazzo
perché non giochiamo a flash come come
giocavamo da piccoli o ti batto 10 a 0
è per questo che sei tanto incazzato
vero o una foto di jeff con me anche
bella riunione di famiglia
eravate felici insieme vero che è free
non fare gli scherzi brutto stronzo che
poi titolo tiro in testa bicchiere da ok
siamo usciti sono uscito miracolosamente
non so come fatemi salvare prima che
qualcuno mi stupri ci ho trovato una
chiave che bello hanno un pezzo di carta
l'ospedale che bello siamo siamo mica
nell'ospedale no devo andar salvare
mamma
ok e devo andare salvare mamma l'avevo
capito però il problema è che non so
dove mamma devo andare ancora no che
cos'è dove siamo dove cazzo siamo lega
c'è una macchia benissimo ai 10 anni ma
guida lo stesso chi se ne fotte le
ospita ah sì a sto guida sto guidando il
progetto schifo mio dio e la grafica
ragazzi avete presente gta 5
ecco non è così esattamente dobbiamo
come si sa entro entro direttamente con
la macchina ma è così che cazzo con la
mamma perfetta almeno sono scelti casa
successo qui rega ma perché è tutto buio
se arrivati sono di nuovo all'ospedale
dove all'inizio ragazzi ma non c'è più
nessuno e la cosa inquietantissimo io
torno nella stanza di jeff se torno
dov'era prima jeff ok c'è domanda va
tutto a fuoco siamo ok questa è la
stanza dj frega ci siamo ci siamo non
c'è che sto facendo niente io buongiorno
sei tornato qui che bello senti c'è mica
la mamma che la dietro vero che bello
che sei qui questa foto perché perché
dimmelo jeff per favore non è soltanto
perché sei stato abbandonato vero e per
qualcos'altro
madonna quanto sei sexy te lo dirò
sempre cosa lo fa vai via
tenta di ucc cos'è sta roba chiedevo
perché tenta di ucciderlo a buy via
oppure parla con lui tenta di ucciderlo
vai così michael a quella pistola valgo
a pistola spara veloce veloce ma che
cazzo ma se stupido morte ma porca [ __ ]
proviamo con chiellini ma perché ancora
una volta jeff perché la la la festa
papà e mamma ma donna che festa avete
fatto a perché non mi aveva invitato
stronzi ok vabbè avete fatto un casino o
mio dio il mio libro ii ucciderò
qualcuno la madre liu pai gli uva in
camera tua sono così arrabbiata anch'io
cos'è che stanno facendo tu brutto
stupido bambino non hai nulla da dire
vero hai paura non è così si mamma ho
paura a brutta stronza queste perché sei
stato un bambino cattivo la madonna te
la sei cercata
sono stanca andiamo a dormire tesoro
ok tesoro sì ma siete proprio bastardi
madia ve lo meritate stronzi
vai a dormire ecco perché già felice
sempre va a dormire perché è stata
l'ultima frase che ha sentito ai suoi
genitori
va bene già facciamo così adesso sta
dalla tua parte non avevo capito
effettivamente perché mamma e papà loro
mi hanno picchiato o no non è possibile
e diventato pazzo ha ragione lui no non
è vero
sì l'ho fatto ma io ti ho protetto ogni
volta sono tua madre dopo tutto vero
salva mamma o fai niente ma devo
decidere se salvare mamma o no fai
niente ma [ __ ] [ __ ]
no non puoi
vai così ragazzi sta finendo malissimo
mai così brutto stronzo fai quello che
devi jeff io di appoggio questo perché
non mi hai comprato le figurine [ __ ]
più dandy grandissimo ragazzi ho finito
il jazz the killer è vero è carino come
cosa anche se comunque come storia
abbastanza corta non ha fatto abbastanza
bene mi è piaciuto parecchio quindi
niente complimenti a chi l'ha fatta
devo ancora finire comunque finali di
libri perché mi avete chiesti in tanti
finirò anche quelli più avanti con che
ragazzi lo so non mi piace ha vinto se
siete d'accordo con me che la mamma
doveva soffrire dopo comunque va beh
lasciamo perdere tutto sto casino la
solita ragazzi se vi è piaciuto al
documento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che oneri video trovate nella
descrizione se ne servì rischi fischiati
vene ci rimettiamo in un prossimo video
ragazzi